for me it was 24 years ago I was working
with you on The Simpsons we believe that
I know and that's when I got the phone
call during a Simpsons record and they I
got on the phone and a voice literally
said you're the new host of late-night
get going kid and told 1940s guy yeah do
that I had one of those candle [ __ ] this
is really five to five exactly but I
remember thinking either Simpsons have
been on for years this thing's pretty
much done I'm ready yeah good luck
suckers without me you know what's funny
though is that you have your I told us
two people all the time they asked me
what it was like to work work there and
I said these the the people that do the
voices the actors that provide the
voices provide so much of that soul of
that show the you know the writing is
obviously good but you guys really
inhabit so many amazing characters and I
know that doing voice is like even
watching your new show Brock Meyer I can
tell that this is a character that
you've probably attacked almost through
the voice first trying to figure out
what he sounded like
he's a baseball announcer and thinking
that's how you work
oh yeah and whenever I often do vocally
driven characters have throughout my
career and and this baseball announcer
voice the voice of Jim Brock Meyer is a
voice that I keyed into as a teenager
the generic baseball announcer voice of
the seventies I call it also the voice
that showed you the Ginsu knife
Edinburgh and Pope use kitchen magicians
yeah yeah I remember that
yeah I was fascinated like do these guys
always sound this way became the comedic
premise one of the first ones through
did you what you when you so you were a
kid doing voices anyone who's good at
voices that's not my talent but we're
still looking for that but but but I
know that anyone I talk to who's very
good at voices was doing it when they
were kids were there people that you
mimicked as a child you know everyone in
the house that your relatives yes i
imitated everyone I heard relatives the
some came in handy
migrant my paternal grandmother I did a
very dead-on impression of hi know my
paternal my father's mother right and
who my mother didn't always get along
with and so I would freak out my mom
occasionally if she would come home
I'd be in the kitchen hi honey I'd be
like hello honey how are you and my
mother would I can he little pause of
what I knew was being filled with
intense fear and hatred on her part yeah
then hiya mom just me Mom sorry
how how angry was she when she found
that it was you again it was a
combination of tremendously relieved
that yeah yeah that my dad's mom wasn't
actually there and then very annoyed at
me yeah I got a lot of that a lot of
dismissive you know we're all gonna talk
in our own voices at the table tonight
right which was directed at me
right you're never gonna earn your
living that way so knock it off yeah
you